welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace and Helbig the
first today is very exciting we have
Claudia Saluki here with us she's a
youtuber she's a brand new fashion mogul
and she will debunk any ideas that you
had of riding horses in the ocean as
being romantic get rid of you for an
episode that you can't forget turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind with
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain Claudia thank you so much for
being here
oh my god thank you so much for having
of course this is so exciting I see you
wearing a lot of jewelry I am wearing
are you wearing any from your new line
oh my god that's so bad because I'm no
that's okay that's okay it's all very
good jewelry but I mean I'm sure yours
is baby I'm wearing one of my shirts I
mean this is just a basic but I love it
I'm just let's talk this is the biggest
thing that's happening right now you
just by the time this podcast goes out
this will be you know a little bit in
the past but you just announced that you
have a line with at Nordstrom mmm this
is crazy
talk to us about this oh my gosh yeah
it's so surreal I mean it's it's a brand
that I've shopped at my entire life like
yeah it's so the collaboration was is
with Nordstrom BP which is one of their
sort of branches and sections that's
been around for around like 30 years and
I've never really partnered with anyone
on it or made anyone like the face of it
or anything so this is new for them it's
new for me and the opportunity came
around like late last year okay I I feel
like when I first got it I didn't
process what was happening I kind of was
like you know just cool yeah let's meet
up
and then in January had my first trip
out to Seattle because that's where the
headquarters are and I had to meet you
know like 50 people from Nordstrom all
of them being women it was so empowering
Wow and also so intimidating Oh
intimidating I basically had to fly over
there and sort of like convince them
that I'm the girl to do yeah it was we
kind of had to like pitch myself and how
I can you know contribute to you know
promoting the line and all my creative
ideas and stuff very intimidating but it
was so great they're all so sweet that's
cool cuz this is more than just like a
youtuber making merch this is an actual
like fully formed clothing and
accessories lie and like you have
everything so I didn't even realize that
going into it I there so once once it
was official contracts were signed I met
with all of the departments I didn't
realize that I was gonna meet with a
bunch of different departments I thought
it was just gonna be a few t-shirts and
pants and dresses yeah and so we met
with like clothing shoes accessories
pajamas intimates hair scrunchies
jeweler like scrunchies has its own
section I mean that's solely responsible
for scrunchies just grungy I wish we
took it seriously you know I hand-picked
all of the materials and colors and what
the Col yeah
just fun where do you even start with
something like that because I watched
your announcement video and like all of
the kind of the promo videos for it and
you seemed really hands-on with it it's
not like you're just taking a bunch of
photos and clothes that they've already
picked out that you're gonna put your
name on em hmm yeah how does that
process work it's so I feel like you can
relate on this with just having a
background of YouTube where you're so
used to having control of everything and
so I sort of that's you know trickles
into everything that I work on where I
just want to see everything that's
happening and want to kind of sort of
add my input into everything and the
cool thing about doing it with Nordstrom
is they've been doing this for obviously
so long
they're such professionals and they do
everything so fast and so they had so
much to bring to the table being like
all right so these silhouettes these
pieces were you know there's a trend
forecast of what's gonna do well at what
time of year and so we had outlines and
things and the first thing we started if
the first thing we started off with
colors like what the color palette is
gonna be I was like I for sure need
purple I'm obsessed the purple team
favorite we did like purple mustard
yellow and red great yeah and then we
went into patterns and they had like a
few starting patterns and then I would
get super specific and be like well
let's blow this one out change the color
to this change the code to that let's
look at the other ones I had them I had
someone from like the print department
bring an entire book of prints and I was
just going through all of them and
changing things and so once we got those
established then we sort of we kind of
were just like tacking patterns and
colors to different silhouettes that we
had planned and kind of envisioning what
it looks like as a whole because we
wanted to make sure that you can create
outfits within the line right you know
and so I mean just like every single
time I fell out there I was like amazed
because of how fast and efficient they
work it was so fun that's so cool and
like the fun byproduct is that you get
to just have a bunch of clothes that you
design that you get to wear now we have
an entire clothing rack in my bedroom
that's dedicated just to be P times
Claudius loose key that's so cool yeah
how do you keep something like that a
secret for so long you don't I told
everyone in my life oh my god I was so
dramatic with it I took my mom was
visiting me and I brought her to the
Grove Nordstrom and I like sat her in
the baby section and I was like so
mother you know this section guess whose
face is going to be in this section do
you have a background in art well I've
always been like a crafty gal sure loved
art class loved painting yeah I paint a
lot to sort of reduce stress and chill
out a good way to do it it is really
good
and I've always liked sorta
done weird little crafty things like in
school growing up I would say my first
business was bookmark drawing in third
grade drawing bookmark I would draw
bookmarks and laminate them with tape
and like like sell them to like teachers
and students and I had characters I had
this like frog character that people
would ask you to draw the Frog in
different situations like draw the Frog
playing hockey for life my one friend
anyways so that was a booming business
yeah you were already an entrepreneur
yeah we got and then that followed by
soap making I made soaps natural
childhood activities like lip balms and
like little jars and stuff and like the
Prophet wasn't great because I was
spending so much money on little
canisters glycerine and fragrances my
parents are like okay you know whatever
keeps you busy
somehow so I think I just love adding my
creativity to anything so this was such
a fun way that's so cool just and it
must feel nice because you've been doing
YouTube for how long now ten years ten
years a decade this years ten years yeah
and so it must be nice to kind of have a
different outlet for your creative
energy mm-hmm because how what are your
thoughts and feelings on on YouTube
currently or like how is your evolution
gone I'm in a great place right now I
feel like everyone goes through hills
and valleys of it and I feel like the
thing that's sort of stuck with me is my
content is just very relative to
whatever I'm going through yeah you know
what I mean if I'm moving I'm all about
the moving vlogs if I'm you know working
on something I'm all about that and so
that kind of sort of helps me stay fresh
with my content because I've never
really fallen into the pattern of like
doing trends on YouTube I'm the worst
youtuber in that sense like I barely
watch those videos and I don't know
what's trending I just sort of do
whatever
want but yeah I'm in a place right now
where I recognize how special this is I
feel like for a while you know maybe
YouTube wasn't considered that serious
or there's negative connotations towards
it because of some of the crazy because
but essentially YouTube and Instagram
and all that stuff they're just
platforms and tools to create whatever
you want so it's it's whatever you make
of it sure so that's just what I remind
myself that's very healthy didn't think
of it that way you know I should I try
you big you're big into Instagram then
to love Instagram is that more of your
number one um it kind of is that this
right now well I would never like I've
never used IG TV I just I can't I don't
know how he would do it's Mike Lincoln
accidentally all the time yeah and then
I feel like I've entered like an
alternate dimension and I don't know how
to get out thing that we should be doing
I asked that all the time and I'd my
answer to myself as no okay I feel like
by the time I actually get it figured
out they'll be like mmm it's gone fun
it's a feature that we tried and no one
used it and my bag has figured it out
please know that's what I'm terrified of
so I mean you do Ben Instagram
definitely the biggest I suck on Twitter
I'm so bad there's a whole minefield now
like I think everyone sucks on Twitter
right is true so you're not alone do you
who do you follow on like Instagram like
who's your go-to to look at right now
I'm really into following like shelter
and dog adoption accounts oh that's
great really want to adopt a dog oh is
that is that the next big project that's
so funny it's totally a project as a
youtuber you're like well I'm gonna make
these books about the dog and I'm gonna
do it no but I'm just obsessed with pit
bulls right now so that's the first
thing that came to mind you know what
also though this is very recent as of
like this morning have you seen you see
some crazy content about fish lately
did you see the fish being like shot out
of a plane yes the trout yes someone
created like it so one day being [ __ ]
abused in a different way I don't know
what's going on I don't know is it good
are they doing a good thing yeah they're
likely but it looks like very violent
Isaac like what I'm wondering is how are
they doing once they get back in that
water you know like yeah wellness checks
like follow-ups like are they do they I
don't know where they depress are they
going to keep making little fishies also
our other scientists like seeing this
realizing like this is helpful and now
feel challenged to create the next most
ridiculous way to get fish from one
place next I have no idea I'm very
excited it does distract me from the
horrors of the world so if that's what
it takes I say more fish content please
well the sad thing is I watched that
video this morning and I liked before
reading the tweet I just saw the video
and I thought it was plastic being shot
out of a flow like it look like little
pieces of plastic fish like this makes
sense like dumping plastic everywhere
well did you see the thing about like it
raining plastic now no oh good yeah I
saw this yesterday what's going on
articles I forgot where it is but like
particles are of plastic are being you
know what is the word made into rain
yeah like advanced no yeah it's in the
snow it's in the rain uh-huh and it's
yeah so now great yeah at least we got
rid of straws this is true here we are
our first step one step at a time I love
your vlogs and I watched a ton of your
moving vlogs when you moved your place
is beautiful by the way and I watch them
because there's something so satisfying
about watching someone decorate like
with thought and like meticulously
what do you cuz your vlogs are so just
authentically yourself and you hanging
out and you and your boyfriend what do
you choose to show versus what do you
not choose to show do you have like kind
of a line drawn in your head of like how
much of your personal life gets put
online good question um I feel like for
starters since I've been doing this for
so long I sort of just at this point
know what's worth showing and what's
your not worth showing as far as like
filters are being patient with releasing
some news and that because you know it's
like once you put something out it's out
there everyone can judge it but uh in
terms of like vlogging with other people
like you said with my boyfriend we this
year we went on a Cabo trip and I did
this like whole thing or every time we
go on cute trips I always vlog it cuz
it's super cute yeah memories and every
time he's like wow I like never when I
look back on the trip I don't think of
you being on your camera outlet but you
filmed so much and you made it look like
yeah you know it and I think it's all
about the way that I look at vlogging is
like when I when I pull out a camera
it's an opportunity to like make
something happen if something's already
happening I don't want to ruin it by
pulling out a camera sure so instead
like when I pull out a camera that's
when I want to sort of just like make a
joke or say something funny and that
kind of helps to not like disrupt the
the present and whatever is already
happening no one really likes when you
like you're like oh can you say that
again I would rather authentically
create a memory just on camera and he's
so game and all my friends are so game
to do that and so I think it's a little
bit of that and a lot of just montage
clips you know just like keep the camera
like low down get some music in there
super thoughtful but I just I logging is
my favorite I love it and that is where
I feel like my community is just like
the most interactive yeah and I'm like
alright you guys should I put this chair
in this corner like that one for sure so
I love the moving vlogs
yeah that's great is there anyone that
you watch online that's similar to that
or like do you watch YouTube videos yeah
I go through phases
right now yes I'm slacking but vlogs are
always the most fun because you just
it's so personal and so you fall into a
rabbit hole but I watch a lot of my
friends oh gosh you do watch a lot of
your friends video yeah really yeah oh
yeah
that's real sweet I don't I think I'd be
like are you doing don't say that don't
do that sweet
okay let's talk what your boyfriend how
did you guys meet each other oh my gosh
so basically any bottom line yeah
fitness so fitness as a musician writes
music produces music sings music so he
we have some mutual or he's worked with
my friends in the past okay so for the
past like two years my friend Rebecca
and drew have like brought him up in
conversations being like oh my god I
just had a session with this guy you
know you guys were like really hit off
but it's not worth it cuz he's always
out of town and so I never thought this
guy never mind you guys did it up I
think he had like a girlfriend at the
time - actually I remember but I always
remembered the name Phineas because
Phineas yes it and we actually
technically met through a dating app
really on my phone just like scrolling
through profiles I saw his name and I
was like is this the man's she was like
oh my god yes it is it's like you need
to do it and I think like a week later I
invited him out to the movies with the
two friends that he also knew
non-threatening super just yeah neutral
experience and we hit it off immediately
and that entire week we spent every
single day together and then he was gone
for a week and then we hung out for
another commit was gone and but it like
white caught him right elected a it was
yeah oh that's so sweet
it also takes the pressure off of them
from like initiating the setup love you
guys if it didn't work out oh yeah I
mean all we did was watch a movie so
they just like showed up
it's almost going to be a year it's
where I like almost 11 months now which
like ultimately isn't that that long in
the grand scheme of things but he's just
my best friend and I love him so much
and it feels like I've known him for so
long I know he seems like you guys have
done a ton in the last year yeah that's
what we think about we're just like oh
Jesus Christ we've been on so many plane
so we've done so much I mean and
traveling is like a huge thing for
couples like to find out that's like a
make or break situation totally um and a
lot of couples can probably date for a
long time before they even get to that
travel face right it's kind of
skyrocketed right there because there's
two things that could have gone against
us the first one is you know having that
long-distance sort of aspect but it
works because I keep myself busy and he
keeps himself himself busy so when he's
gone like right now he's gone for three
and a half weeks yeah we obviously cried
before we said goodbye it was very
dramatic but I'm also like okay great I
can get back into yeah and so it helps
to kind of keep each other and check and
like get a bunch of work done but at the
same time we get to travel together
which is so much fun and that could be a
stressful experience if like you know
you don't travel well or you - just
sorry whatever but we're just both so
chill and always just like want to have
fun and yeah where's like the coolest
place you guys have been this year maybe
Australia I mean that was my first time
oh really went west really how was that
um it was crazy at first we obviously
hopped around a bunch because they were
touring and we went to this island
called Magnetic Island it was the most
insane day of my life we like took a
helicopter onto this island we get onto
the island we get on a boat for like two
hours we're swimming around then we get
on two horses we start riding the
bruises in the ocean which by the way is
commercialized as such a fun thing and
I'm
actually gonna bunk that right now
because horse poop floats okay
actually let me wait let me like jump
back you see also the saddles that we
had so first of all this like horse
riding experience it was so beautiful
sure but it was like 2 or 3 hours long
and like sometimes you know pennies and
I had like little patience we're like
okay this is so awesome but like come on
we're like riding for an hour it's
beautiful it's hot we're kind of
sweating then we're about to get on to
the beach to go through the water and we
had to take the saddles off because they
can't get wet so we're like barebacked I
think that's called I'm like you have
nowhere to put your feet so you're just
like totally on for dear life and the
horse is so tall this is my first time
we're like going in a line in the ocean
and just one by one each horse starts
pooping it is literally just like
hitting your shins and he was like oh no
oh dear God Oh Claudia your horse is
shedding definitely not advertising the
brochure No so every time we see like on
Instagram like an insta body like riding
a horse
oh [ __ ] there we go we know what this is
actually like you know your shins got
[ __ ] that's so funny oh god I love that
romantic excursion is the nastiest rally
it was great beautiful listen it led to
a great story so I'll take it but in the
moment oh my god okay we're gonna take a
quick break okay when we get back I have
a ton more questions for you and then
Twitter we'll have some questions for
you we'll be right back with more nacho
deep woo
[Music]
I bet you have a dream that you'd like
to turn into a reality it will get his
weather good buds at Squarespace can
help you do it they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project you
want to start a new business showcase
that work publish your content sell your
products or more Squarespace is a tool
for you
they've beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website yourself so where
spaces powerful ecommerce functionality
lets you sell anything online and they
have analytics that help you grow your
site in real time everything is
optimized for mobile right out of the
box and there's nothing to patch your
upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get to help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support they empower millions
of people designers lawyers artists
gamers restaurants gyms
to turn great ideas into something real
so head to squarespace.com slash grace
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain that squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace all right
we're back clean chins ready to go okay
now let's talk about acting okay you do
a ton of it as there's always been
something that you wanted to pursue yeah
so growing up it was always something
that I was fascinated by like I always
wanted to do it way before YouTube but
never really knew how to go about it
yeah I didn't do theater I don't know by
the time I started YouTube I didn't have
enough time sure but when I moved out to
Los Angeles I was 18 well yeah I was
very young I can't believe my parents
let me do that you didn't like the LA
story I really did do the LA story I did
it hard yeah I remember like the day
that I moved I had been planning this
for you know eight months where I'm
gonna live my roommate everything and
the day I was supposed to drive across
bought myself a car it's gonna drive
across country drive across country by
yourself with my parents with your
parents okay but I told my dad like hey
today's the day and he was like what
like we're moving he's like what like
today I'm like yeah do you not see all
of the boxes I've been packing up my
life for two weeks he you know he's
shifted some things around to come
god bless but okay acting yeah so I
moved out to LA sort of the idea of like
okay great YouTube is so fun it's going
so great but what else do I want to do
yes I knew this was like the route that
I wanted to pursue and keep going and
see where it takes me and so I came in
with open arms and at that time I
started working with awesomeness a lot
and they did so many different things I
started doing like acting not acting
hosting stuff so I had like this show
with them for Android where I had
different guests on we were doing
different things and that led into me
hosting for Teen Vogue I became their
like first-ever YouTube hosts so I would
cool I would cover red carpets and
interview celebrities and been a real
treat real fun memorizing specific
questions for specific people having
yeah just basically like two flashcards
of who everyone is constantly oh I would
do like little code words and then save
it as my lock screen on my phone so I'd
like to see someone and then like the
three words that I gave myself and then
I would you know that's very smart
Trexler yeah and so I did that for a
year and it was it was such a great
experience it was so fun and it it made
me feel very just like fulfilled and
excited at the moment everything and
once that sort of wrapped up I thought
to myself well I
it doesn't challenge me as much as it
did in the beginning when you're when
you're doing that you're sort you just
like channel this energy like hey guys
I'm you know what I mean it yeah and
that's great for some people but I
wanted to try something else and so
that's when I had the moment to myself
for I was like okay whoa if someone had
told me that I would have done this you
know just a few years ago I would have
never believed them and acting was
always something that I wanted to try
but I felt like I sort of had like
imposter syndrome where I was like who
am I to jump into this you know I've
never done theater and don't know much
about it and I'm just youtuber and all
that stuff but thinking about you know
hosting and how I just jumped into that
like without you know totally blinded
and was able to do that and have so much
fun with it I you know called my manager
at the time when was just like I don't
know how this works but if you ever get
any up like if there's any opportunity
to go in on an audition I would love to
I I don't know and I quickly booked this
show called tagged that I think there's
three seasons out on Hulu okay and that
was just such pure luck
like I just fit the character and so I
was able to do it and it was so much fun
what's that show so it's called tag and
it's about these three girls that get
blackmailed by this guy named monkey man
and he like shot someone and everyone
has a secret it's it's your classic sort
of high school thriller drama and it
gets really intense and it had like it
has like a really cult following like it
was so fun so my best friends are you
know people that I've met on that show
and so that's sort of like gave me the
bug mm-hmm and you know made me realize
how much I want to do this and so I just
continued to act in different things and
book different projects and I got agents
and now I'm at the point where I've got
a coach that I'm working with multiple
times a week on everything and it's
definitely my main focus even if I
haven't like filmed anything in a year
whatever because the auditions that I go
out for are like the the big league
stuff Network television shows and huge
movies and everything and so it's all
about just like when the right thing
comes the right thing comes yeah and
that's I think I like didn't realize
that going into it either that the
acting industry there's so many people
and it's and you know it's all about
like connections and just going into
casting directors many times and
building those relationships it's a
whole beast that I was unaware of but
I'm so down I'm game and it's something
that I take really seriously and I love
it I enjoy it so much it's always when
you least expect it to yeah it's always
when you truly don't think you're right
for some
they're like no you're at you're like
huh so now I'm busy for the next two
months okay yeah okay do you have any
ridiculous auditioning stories or
embarrass this audition it like sounds
awful but ended up being so great so it
was it was for this like horror thing or
something okay and the last scene was
the the characters like looking in the
mirror and she's like brushing her teeth
or something and then she like looks
down and she looks up and some things
differ on her face then she looks down
there's like worms in the sink then she
looks up there's someone behind her like
it was like a whole thing like granted
out yeah and I was like how do you want
me to do this because no one's talking
with you in the scene yeah and so I'm
going through the movements in my head
and like reacting like bigger bigger
bigger and then for the finale you know
I jump back and like scream right yeah
and there was like like a blanket with
like two tripods stick things holding it
I bump into the tripod like backdrop
almost like falls I think it like it
wiggled but it was fine but I like fell
to the floor dying laughing because it
was so funny but that was and we all
started laughing though they're like no
don't do it again that was great I was
so glad we got a shot but I've had like
also just weird experiences where it's
like such a good time that like the
casting director and I just like hug it
out after you think it's so great like
what's that doesn't happen yeah I yeah
they're just fun nothing sweet that's so
fun I mean god I want you're like
optimism and enthusiasm that great all
the time but like you know hey red you
did stand up no did it never oh no oh my
god I wish that is that's probably my
biggest fear right there yeah I've never
done stand-up before and I feel like
you'd be great at it um it terrifies me
I've done like storytelling and stuff
like that but straight up like here are
my rehearse jokes I have a real hard
time with that
yeah is there anything that you haven't
done yet that you really want to do um
that's a great question um I really just
want to continue getting into like the
business side of things really like I
don't I don't know where this BP thing
will continue to go and how far it will
and who knows worth what that will turn
into or you know whatever but sort of
being able to like see the business side
of things and starting to just branch
out on things that are off of YouTube
excites me yeah and so whatever that
leads to like I just wanna do more of
that that's awesome yeah talk to me
about beautycon okay I've never been
what's it like it's a convention it's a
lot more tame than like VidCon and
playlist though I know you get to walk
away with trash bags full of god bless I
did it this year because I I was like
this is overwhelming I I'm in and out
and I I didn't unfortunately I did not
go I was so hungry in the buffet line
and was so long and I was like I'm not
even gonna do that I didn't to get
myself food which is insane but no
beautycon is so fun it's just like you
know all the different vendors and
makeup companies and booths and stuff
and everyone is just very respectful and
sweet yeah this year I had like a panel
with my friend Lauren Elizabeth and
after the panel you know a bunch of
people wanted to meet us and they all of
them were just you know waited their
turn it was far oh my it's so sweet I
was like wow I feel holier and just more
pure and just sweet after this
experience yeah you feel like you've
been treated like like a human I totally
yeah yeah great do you have a particular
convention that you prefer oh I mean I
haven't been to any other in Seoul I'm
such a Patti youtuber I'm so bad no no
no you're fine my first one was playlist
live Orlando and I I don't know if any
can top that one cuz that was just the
first time of me being like youtuber boy
oh my god I know all these people
yeah yeah and all the network parties
just you know oh yeah we know yeah oh
yes I've tied on many of you all those
parties I had to I had to cut off myself
but it is so fun when you're walking for
the first time and you see all these
people that you've seen on the internet
you're like I know them yeah know them
know them I mean the jarama was crazy
like one of my friends Rebecca Black I
remember like our first time meeting we
she like kissed some boy I didn't know
her yet and he kissed me the next day or
something and that was like literally my
first one I think but now you guys are
good oh my god I'd love her to that yeah
sweet
that's so sweet what do you guys do for
fun ooh great question um what do we do
for fun god I work just a lot I my
social life has just watch stuff what do
you watch yeah okay um well I finished
euphoria hey did you watch I have not
watched it's it's pretty good it's
pretty good it's good okay my friend
Lucas is in it so I wanted to like
support him and watch it yeah and the
entire show is just like a giant music
video really I just it was interesting
to watch just from like a filming and
storytelling perspective and the music
like didn't Drake score the show or like
how you're asking the wrong sure I don't
like the music was just insane and the
colors and everything he just like you
feel like you're watching and you're
like on drugs you know like a very
trippy show yeah so that that was fun to
watch
um relax I mean painting I get it girl
you would live a very busy light oh okay
you were saying before that you went on
tour with Phineas yeah I tried I joined
when I can okay what's that experience
like is it I mean it's it's so great I
love his family so much it's such a
great opportunity to always just be
together with them because you know
there
traveling so often so I personally like
love the lames
like for them it's lame but for me like
I love sleeping and like the tour bunks
oh yeah yeah they're just like these
little coffins I'm like a little a
little cluster phobic so like if I fall
asleep along the wall I freak out in the
middle of night I switch over and make
it a whole thing but besides that like
it's so foreign to me that I'm like oh
my god we're gonna sleep on a tour bus
so he's like no this isn't this sucks
but so that's really fun and it's it's
really crazy to just sort of see the
behind the scenes of it all you know
just as far as like airport travel and
stuff like in Australia it was crazy
they let you just go to the gate as long
as you go through security if you don't
have a plane ticket you can just be at
the gate and so all of the different
like flights we would do like there
would be fans out at the gate really
crazy that's nuts
it's really crazy and Billy does such a
great job and like making sure to say hi
everyone and being so sweet to everyone
but sometimes it's just like whoa like
this is taken time up you know yeah but
it's really crazy to see that it's
really exciting to watch - I think just
seeing that and dating him it's like so
inspiring because they're such hard
workers it just makes me want to do the
same
it's yeah so that's that's sweet yeah
that's real sweet I can imagine it's
probably so incredibly hectic yeah and
I'm like like a group I'm a groupie now
- that's like that's like on my resume a
full-time groupie as well when I can be
[Music]
do you have an earthquake emergency kit
prepared
oh no oh my god I've been thinking about
this for honestly ever since those two
big ones over at 3 I don't even I wasn't
even in town for them so I missed them
where were you when they happened so
there was one on 4th of July right and
then like Tim the next day so I didn't
feel the one on 4th of July because I
was in a car but um I felt the other two
and I was home alone and like my entire
I have like a law for the high ceiling
which just freaks me out even more
because there's so much wind oh yeah the
whole thing was shaking and like I'm
from Chicago I don't really know what
you're supposed to do I know you're
supposed to like go under heavy
furniture door
avoid Windows yeah but now it's my voice
I know it was so in shock that like when
it happened I was just sitting on the
floor like writing something I just like
like this like I just post it up and
didn't move and that one ended up being
like a minute or two long which was so
long it was under minute long I didn't
know and the whole time I was like what
do i do what do i do what do i do what
do i just rose which is probably the
worst thing but like okay where do we
get these kids when a son has a lot of
like prepackaged kits okay last I
checked but that was like last year and
what I used to put it just anywhere
anywhere anywhere cuz what's in the kids
Jake here's some food that'll last first
and water and that sort of thing and
then there's some other stuff I don't
even know so do you run to the kit in
the middle of a bucket under some heavy
furniture I should put my kit in the
place I should be when the earthquake
happens and that's how I'll know where
to go yeah there's that I mean I feel
like also in the wake of these
earthquakes yeah there's gonna be so
many like I'm surprised target doesn't
have some like cute ass little
earthquake kit for everyone true I mean
I I mean if Jo Jo see wha doesn't come
out with a Josie wha earthquake at
Target I don't know what she's gonna do
I don't know what she's doing
but we'll work on that I think it's an
easy Amazon it isn't easy Amazon for
Josh I think you're right okay we're
gonna take one last break when we get
back twitter has lots of questions for
you Claudia so we'll be right back with
more nacho deep cove is on a mission to
make migraines less of a headache it
begins with a simple consultation from
the convenience of your own home a
licensed doctor reviews your symptoms
and determines the best course of
treatment for you then your personalized
supply of medication is delivered
directly to your door each treatment
plan is personalized and tailored to you
and a few weeks after you begin your
treatment
Kove will reach out through there
patient portal 2 check how you're
feeling Kove offers both acute and
preventative medications and everything
prescribed by copes doctors is
fda-approved there is no medical
insurance needed sign up for Cove and
receive your first month of medication
free and we can attest to this because
Melissa producer director extraordinaire
here and not too deep actually uses this
and we all know I give her God dang
headaches she's actually taking this
swears by a very secure very easy system
she went on their website she filled out
a questionnaire it's super simple super
straightforward and bing-bang-boom
she's happy so if you suffer from
migraine headaches the last thing you
need is to wait to see a doctor with
Cove there's finally a way to get the
help you need when you need it
for a limited time get your first month
of medication free by visiting with Cove
dot-com slash grace that's w ith CoV
e.com slash grace whatever struggles
you're facing from depression and
anxiety to trauma and grief better help
can connect you with a professional
counselor in a safe and private online
environment it's so convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist and anything you share is
completely confidential
best of all it's an affordable option
and you listeners will get 10% off your
first month with a discount code grace
so why not get started go to better help
calm slash grace and fill out a
questionnaire to get matched with a
counselor that you'll love today okay
Claudia before we get into Twitter
questions when I ask you the two
questions ask every single guest that's
on the podcast and the first is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at okay I thought
about this episode I was like do I go
serious and say like you know Trump but
if we're gonna take it personal for the
past few months okay
my neighbors fight so much every day
morning middle the night mid-afternoon
dinnertime one shot it is it is to the
point where like I'm just like the
fighters are at it again
like we just did all the lighters and
can you hear the words they're saying to
each other
I can when they're out on the balcony
Wow
yeah it's not at this point I'm like
this is why are you guys still in this
relationship know what I mean like this
is like you are not helping either
but okay I feel like I'd never be the
type to like just walk in and like throw
spaghetti I thought this one through so
I wouldn't necessarily do that but like
I imagine there's like a world where
they're in the middle of a fight they're
going at it and just like the entire
ceiling maybe just like opens up and
it's just like that might be the wake-up
call needs to even realize that they
need to leave the relationship or they
need to make some like concrete change
like they gotta like get the [ __ ] out of
the movie cuz I'm sick of it I just
imagine like just so much spaghetti
falling everywhere and just that's
incredible that's a beautiful visual
thank you so much spaghetti okay the
other question is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story or close call you
can only use three words or three small
phrases mine is college jogging front
lawn okay Mexico oh let me let me say
this dude okay Mexico to New York panel
oh no about to walk on oh no oh no no no
a big oh no
that's like more sad than it is funny I
can I can imagine that situation and
there's no good like maybe the worst
situation well you made it through you
survived okay now let's get into these
Twitter questions we had so many for you
a lot of people wanted to know what is
the most challenging part of designing a
clothing line or designing the line in
general I would say the most challenging
part has also been like the biggest
blessing and it's the fact that it was a
collaboration hmm because I'm a control
freak I just want it you know what I
mean sure and so I would say the most
challenging part was you know agreeing
on everything and it definitely was like
as smooth as it could ever be but of
course when you're designing and you're
putting your all into something like
sometimes you're like nervous about
literally one thing like how my sock
looks yeah so it's sort of that stuff
and sort of putting my trust into a
brand that's like we know our customer
like our customer is gonna love this and
like this will help and so it was like
finding that middle ground of like this
is a 50/50 collaboration but at the same
time that was like the blessing because
there's so much that I don't know about
creating a line that was like this is so
great to have someone holding my hand
the whole time and being able to guide
me with you know what will work and what
doesn't work and stuff so probably that
we're just like a little cycle like a
little over controlling sometimes a
passion that's all someone's know what's
your favorite piece from your clothing
line ooh
okay um well I love all the patterns
like there's like this star pattern that
I have this little star tank so that's
got to be my favorite pattern I believe
but I have this like little patent
leather like black backpack that also
turns into a purse oh I saw this he's
convertible
that's cute she's got many faculty many
fun
yeah so you like you've got the backpack
but then there's like a lever if you
pull at the top then it like tightens
the this drag straps and it just turns
into one straps you can just sling it
over that's great very convenient very
convenient
yes one-stop shop yep what's like the
price point on something like that um
it's the only that I don't accept I
don't know exactly that price point but
I do know the range yeah it goes from
$16 to 89.95 so every 100 yeah that's us
for Nordstrom yeah that's amazing yeah
so that was a big thing that we want to
make sure was that
let's make these as like the most
affordable we can yeah um so inclusivity
in that and also the size range to I'm
so excited and proud about that too it
goes from extra extra small to four
times extra large that's fantastic and
like that's one of the great things
about doing it with Nordstrom is like
that we were able to do that you know I
think a lot of like youtubers that make
clothing lines or whatever you know it's
not even just about them not wanting to
make it so expansive but I mean I don't
know what goes into it but maybe they
can't you know there's there let me Shea
and stuff and so that was a huge thing
where I was like yes oh my gosh let's
definitely do that that's fantastic so
everyone can chop it yeah very cool
someone wants to know what's your
biggest irrational fear mayonnaise
mayonnaise Mayo mayonnaise yeah I think
Manny no mayo oh my god man a devil's
condiment oh it's so it like gives me
the shivers thinking about it really I
don't I don't know why Wow yeah that's
not I mean you're not the first person
that's thought mayonnaise is totally
disgusting how do you feel about me I
feel pretty decent about I mean I feel
pretty neutral okay about it like a
light spread yeah I'm not like skewed
like eating it with a spoon someone out
there is right now
when I was younger I got we played truth
or dare and someone dared meet it like
completely like dip a grape and Tamayo
no that was the start the start
boy seedling the irrational year I got
bat oh that's a bad friend cousin to bad
cousin back husband oh you talk about
tags justice someone to know what was
her favorite memory while she was on tag
Joe ooh okay if so fun cuz it we've shot
it in Albuquerque New Mexico so it just
felt like camp that's we they do this
like hot air balloon festival once a
year I believe and we were there around
that time and so we all including like
the director the whole cast we woke up
at like 5:00 a.m. and just watched
hundreds of hot-air balloons just like
lifting up into like we were where they
were all parked just walking through
like drinking like apple cider with
blankets thank you like so cute you
wanted to cry itself but on the other
side of that not so cute things we also
just like hold so many shenanigans like
we stayed at the same hotel every time
so like all the workers in the hotel
knew us and so we would just like we
would run that hotel there just like ran
around and like we'd be riding like the
suitcase like carts up and down
elevators and like it was surprisingly
we never got in trouble but like we
definitely pushed some buttons about it
really was like camping so cute yeah
someone's to know if you could get paid
in anything other than money what would
you want whoa
you know that's a tough question it's a
really tough question because I like
first I think of food but like what kind
of food it's got to be a food that you
won't get sick of you donate right right
right
gift cards that is my plane tickets
maybe plane ticket oh that's true but
like are you gonna be traveling for else
in real life like flames themselves are
not that one no I don't know that's a
tough one what about like something
diamonds
[Music]
what has a great resale value yeah what
doesn't depreciate yeah someone snow
what's your best productivity hack ooh
um self timers oh my gosh if there's
something like doing like a 20 minute
timer have you ever tried this no I
don't think so okay I'm about to rock
your world
okay so if you have like some chores to
do at home or like any sort activity a
lot of things like you can get done in
20 minutes 20 minutes is a good amount
of time but it's also it's so easy to be
distracted have your phone on you and
writing like 100 percent focus if you
set like a 20 minute timer and you're
like okay I'm just gonna like clean this
area for 20 minutes and once the timer
goes off I'm done it like it puts you
into like a game mode and you're like is
it how you like are playing a game with
yourself so I'll do that all the time
like I'm I to to to do us all right like
20 minutes kitchen 20 minutes bathroom I
have my whole place is just cleaned you
know that's so smart doing timers yeah
yeah cuz I am such a mess that like I
have 12,000 like half-finished things
because I'll get distracted and realize
like oh I was doing that but wait then I
have to do this and this and this and
nothing gets completely finished set a
timer Wow
you should I mean is that a pre-existing
system or did you come up with that I
feel like I mmm
maybe I've heard it on YouTube or
something either way great hack great
hat great I'm not gonna take credit for
that one though uh does she still enjoy
living in LA yes she still loves looking
I love it I think yeah a lot of people
just you know say that la is whatever
that sure you know it's extra and the
people are in it an extra are extra and
stuff but I think if you surround
yourself the great friends and
ultimately I love the weather I love
that you can like we're surrounded by
like beaches and mountains and you can
go to the desert and there's so many
things and I think also I'm a homebody
and I love having routine so when I'm
out of it I get a little like you know
stressed out but once I'm able to just
sort of get back into that I think it's
more so just being home yeah and like LA
just it happens to be my home yeah that
makes sense if you could choose
one thing to change about the way others
perceive you what would you pick who
that's a good question
I know I've surprisingly had a lot of
people tell me that I'm nicer than I
look parties or something they're like
you know what you're pretty nice okay do
I have like a crazy like resting
[ __ ] I don't know but I'm trying to
think what else I don't I don't know I
feel like I'm kind of an open book right
I mean that's a good one I mean that's
just out of my control so I can't change
that
yeah but um I don't know I feel pretty
confident and that's great and my first
impressions that's great yeah what's one
thing you never leave the house without
ooh um I mean at this point my KeepCup I
have this it's called keep Cup it's like
this it's like a coffee like a glass
like coffee mug thing uh-huh and I try
to bring it out as much as I can to like
order coffee and have them fill it up in
the cup oh oh that's nice I'm trying
you're giving back to the planet yeah
yeah that's like I feel like that's kind
of a lame answer but no one yeah right
that's a great answer okay um what's
your perfect date idea my perfect date
idea ooh that's a good one I mean I
ooh foreign city exploring that's my
favorite it's like no snow itinerary
no itinerary just walking around like a
new place Wow that's my favorite kind of
date that's so cool like scootering I
don't know something like q yeah is
there a short list of places to go visit
no no I have no idea that is just the
magical thing about my life right now is
like Phineas will just like you want to
come to Minneapolis with me and I'm like
yeah sure okay and then it's like the
best day ever like you want to come to
literally anywhere
just fun cuz it's like a new place
that's so cute yeah um someone wants to
know when did you first know you wanted
to make a clothing line um I mean it was
it was definitely something I've always
kind of thought of because it's just
like what a cool fun dream yeah but that
opportunity sort of just like landed in
my lap I've I've worked with Nordstrom
in the past and but that definitely just
sort of felt like it came out of nowhere
um so I I mean I guess I knew once that
phone call came in and I was like what
no I can't even give credit so the law
of attraction for that one okay last
question which I think I know the answer
what has been the highlight of 2019 in
terms of career and personal achievement
oh yeah that's the clothing night that's
for sure the clothing line I think so
yeah yeah that's so excited well what
they're coming up for the rest of 2019
that's a great question oh man
hmm I feel like I have nothing else sort
of like big lined up or in the works
mm-hmm but that's sort of just an hour
job start to flow into yeah you make
space for things especially this being
such a big baby that you just birth my
gosh yourself some maternity leave yeah
no I'm like letting myself just sit and
chill and just post the content that we
shot for so long you know yes a nice
while we're recording this the line
isn't currently out yet okay um what
comes out August 22nd I'll just my
seconds so when this goes live it will
be out already so where can everyone
find find it find it can they find it in
stores yeah it's um we've gotten in
select stores 33 different stores 32 in
the u.s. one in Canada and then of
course Nordstrom com so that's so cool
crazy I know what a weird thing to say
out loud and it's see a group thing it's
like cried a lot thinking about it it's
very surreal Claudia thank you so much
for being here before you go
though every guest on the podcast gets a
personalized fortune cookie from us to
them so you feel free to open it and
read the fortune that's inside can I say
this is cute this is cute
the cute little cute little fortune
cookie yeah yeah oh my god for a second
I was like oh yeah pranks yeah she's
just a little balled up in there in the
corner mm-hmm little shy girl yeah okay
dupa dupa dupa dupa okay we've also
written a song about you called Claudia
but we don't want to embarrass anyone
with how good it is so we'll keep it to
ourselves for now /e face yeah that's my
favorite as a slashy face is that what
you call it is that what it is or like I
never know having what would you call it
I had just like just like that yeah
wah-wah I'm gonna keep her well I
understand Claudia where can people find
you online if they don't already know um
pretty much just my name Claudia Saluki
it's a long one it's a tough one
I see rally wsk I yeah my Twitter and
Instagram are just Claudia's loose key
as well as my youtube awesome thank you
again so much for being here it's just
so fun they're so fun go check out the
line she's got something for everyone
there and it's all affordable and
adorable and we'll see you guys next
time I'm not upset I'm not too deep good
bye
bye too deep toady Cody not too deep is
a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]